ciao ragazzi il vento grazie a una
puntata di cucina buttata la scorsa
settimana abbiamo fatto la carbonara
ricordo ramsey un risultato eccellente
nonostante gli abomini che abbiamo
dovuto praticare in cucina detto ciò
abbiamo deciso di chiedervi scusa vi
tornare in italia di fare un salto nella
romanità più pura tradizione la
tradizione è il motivo per cui c'è da
luigi siciliano e questo è atto osceno
dell'altra volta lasciamola perdere a
polis oggi facciamo un piatto che tutti
conoscono pure i sassi
stiamo per fare la grecia che per molti
è una carbonara che non ci ha creduto
abbastanza per altre un'amatriciana de
corato ma noi oggi la proveremo con il
nostro maestro gianluigi mai a parlare
gli ingredienti che ci abbia dopo dopo
per fare la gricia avremo bisogno di
pasquale e corino roma mio ranocchio rp
picchio in grani e vino per sfumarsi vii
viii iniziamo gianluigi cosa devo fare
hai fatto per metterti quanti trita
subito il pecorino
se vogliamo la crescita sul finale
dobbiamo tritare il rigorino molto
finemente e guglielmo che qui per questo
prego maestro ok è con safier del turbo
guarda se ne esistono poi sento in forma
esatto anni ne è quello di gomiti è
entrato nei [ __ ] cioè luigi [ __ ]
[ __ ] ci vogliono veramente dieci
minuti per fare questa volta
semplicissima basilare ma dobbiamo
essere accorti sul pezzo finale casa del
tuo accorto to accordo a grattare se
volete provarla volete anche da garci su
instagram per farci vedere i vostri
risultati perché fidatevi che secondo me
questa roba è una bomba
io che chiedo di farla secondo la
tradizione non ci mettete niente sono
due ingredienti in croce che dovete
trovare è nel meridione no prezzemolo
come fa nostra madre l'olio non esiste
lo sa il gordon ramsay metterò gen
non capisce niente fatima riferendo alla
qualità del basta parliamo del soffitto
niente aglio e cipolla niente scalogno
per cortesia cucina povera arte povera
voci sta mettendo troppo ma non è così
facile aspettami seguendo un mio vicino
c'è un tuo parco un po per le scale
avendo tempo a casa mia quando vuoi
mantini puntini non è che per caso un
invito galante parla andiamo avanti con
guanciale ci sta mettendo già troppo
tempo ma passionista nervose e basta te
lo leggo questo guarda quanto ce l'ha
messo a fare il medico sociale come
diego qui che cosa fai eliminerà tutta
la parte di cotica dall'altro lato se
volete tenere da parte che fa da tenete
la reggia rabbia ma raggiungere
direttamente con chiare non c'è una vera
e propria legge seguite voi il vostro
istituto la ricetta tradizionale stai
dicendo presidente arrangiatevi alla
gente esatto perché ci si arrangiava in
passato ho tolto in maniera un po grezza
adesso faremo delle belle fette la
tradotta ragazzi se scegliete di fare
questo piatto abbondate con le cose note
di te ne metto poco perché sto un po
leggeri non so dieta che in sala
facciamo delle bellissime seggiolini che
però non fatelo come questo ragazzi da
qui ne fate uscire tutti a cagare ma per
favore non rompere i [ __ ] sotto
centri
nel frattempo padella ragazzi questa la
porti sempre nelle ricette era questa
ragazzino presenza albegna un
antichissimo chef sardo amazon ingegnere
questo è un piatto che si fa i dieci
minuti con bui e per ognuno 30 che
davvero mi rompe i [ __ ] perché non
tagliano un gratta sta facendo col
guanto nero da killer
semplicemente sono persone 80 all'igiene
usiamo un programma di cucina e successo
a livello nazionale e mondiale del
planetario e non avere
delle norme igieniche da mostrare con i
miei guanti in questo periodo è un atto
ed ecco perché ci metteremo allora un
bel grembiulino loviso stavo dai secoli
questo grembiule mettete likes questa
cosa è una cosa che volete che faccia
più spesso perché usa dimentichiamo
sempre a guardare milano sta avendo
problemi anche ad accendere i fari mamma
mia secondo guanciali padella come una
fiamma molto dolce perché lo facciamo
stufare diceva andiamo a salare
leggermente l'acqua e inseriremo
all'interno la nostra pasta giuliano che
pasta è scelto of scelto nei mezzi
rigatoni perché i mezzi rigatoni
prendono bene i pezzi di guanciale che
si incassa dentro e quindi ogni tanto tu
modo il rigatone c'è una sorpresa dentro
ma va bene anche i tonnarelli o uno
spaghetto alla chitarra basta pasta
mettete la pasta qualsiasi base le
farfalle tutto tranne le paralleli
facciamo mezzo chilo di pasta per sanare
la corrente il sale per ricomparire
utilizzare aprite educate tappo dove
viene prendete le dita in questa maniera
è entrata all'interno del pacco cercate
di andare in fondo range è del tutto
uscite tipo artiglio di pesto rimandate
sopra al bollitore plus offre mastro
titta lasciato fuori il mignolo questo
video ha sconfessato meno supporto e
sostengo la rumbo 14 minuti ma che ci
piace ad est e quindi 12 minuti la
tireremo fuori esattamente ad otto
minuti in modo tale che gli ultimi
minuti rimanenti li butteremo
all'interno della nostra padella
risolviamo il tutto sappiamo cremina e
via giriamo la vasta prima che si
incolla che sin colle che si incolla a
livello il guanciale crispi oppure che
rimane in padella
lo faccio sempre super croccante ma
secondo me e perde un po quando è troppo
croccanti e allora facciamo una cosa lo
lasciamo dentro la patella crispi
orologio cristo gli concede troppo
croccante perde il sapore del guanciale
è diventato un po da casa semplicemente
bruciata
perché lo penale ha parlato col cojone
senza manco tenebra collasso ma siamo in
un canale che ha guardato quel che
voleva la romanità controllatelo sempre
è sfumata la fiamma viva con gli
alcolici e ho imparato una cosa per
capire quando è sfumato tu devi sentire
che non tipica più il naso a chi vuol
dire che l'alcol evaporato esatto lo sta
studiando quanto per la pasta due minuti
chef due minuti e buttiamoci su una casa
per i m così 6 centrato di reparto
chiederci possiamo far vedere chi lo sta
facendo
sembrava gianluigi a un certo punto ha
riconosciuto il guanto da killer ragazzi
prendiamo la pasta scoliamo la
manteniamo sempre l'acqua di cottura e
fondamentale devo a buttarla
direttamente dentro validi con i
doverosamente prendiamo con un mestolo
l'acqua e le inseriamo dentro per far
rilasciare tutti gli ambiti
andiamo con pepe a borsa un minore p io
già piano piano comincia a diventare
molto su che cosa vedi
e ancora non abbiamo aggiunto il
pecorino se avete visto il video della
cacio e pepe
fate il pastello quindi aggiungete un po
di acqua di cottura all'interno del
pecorino e amalgamate tutto è poi
entrato in padella oppure a grossi fino
lo potete aggiungere direttamente sulla
pasta possiamo far pastello come ho
dovuto far bruciare quello così a pala
ne vede biancaneve del presente ma
perché noi dobbiamo dare sempre cose
diverse
giusto organizza mai visto l'ho detto
pure su instagram sembriamo 2 gen
splendide in sorelle con un qualcosa in
più
stiamo usando un magic poi il pazzesco
vero come giudichi il mio salto
non è male non è male non vi spaventate
se la vedete troppo liquida perché tanto
poi col formaggio si rapprende tutto una
domanda già il signor messo il
parmigiano e vedo che è tutto bello
condensato posso aggiungerci l'acqua di
cottura esattamente tutto meno
rigorosamente senza fiamma sommato
proprio nel momento come il più andato
la pasta fuori dalla padella
io non ho mai visto come potete vedere
c'è molta cremina veniamo la fiamma la
stemperiamo leggermente ok e partiamo
per la forma giosa massaggiare non
vedevo assaggiarla yuna cremosità
pazzesca un autore pazzesco mi viene a
piangere l'aspetto è bello anzi patera
suono veramente poco ragazzi due
dettagli non si è portato strepitoso mi
raccomando ragazzi sono arrivati i tag
atc e diteci anche voi priva l'antichità
commentato dicendo viva l'antichità
buonissima la prossima puntata ragazzi
ciao